welcome to this video this is jag 192 j
193 that's a super new account yes won
his first couple of blitz games which
can mean anything from super GM to ya 22
a lot worse ok Jesse we have them have
the two lights let's see what he's doing
yeah this is the currently plate
unfashionable line with Bishop d3 i'm
not an expert I know that this is a
viable option ok 93 that's early
and yeah okay I don't really know what
to do tonight a for Bishop before was so
not clear to me but ok let's develop
this first end maybe I can get it f5 now
f-5e for would be excellent if I get
this in yes he can we can trade but the
deaths involve the time loss how do I
play though I can't play Bishop a six
maybe wonder if this is an idea just
trying to avoid the trades or maybe take
it maybe take it and then retreat this
Bishop there and Queen f6 I don't know
I don't know
Queen g for the light squares are
somewhat and somewhat weakened I still
have this weird night on a five they're
not ideal but I thought that maybe the
screen is still can be a liability and
in the long run keeps going for 90 for
him
yeah it's not a good position what can
you do not good at all now from the
absolutely nothing here forum for my
porn on the quieter quite the opposite
yeah okay now I have to get this back
somehow back into the game not not easy
oh yeah and that's really not good so
anyway to get rid of this is pesky notes
them I cannot even play 96 now
yeah it's a remarkably bad position 97 I
don't know that's really really bad
press the f5 night is even more
problematic than the 49 this is why I
tried to trade this at least he can
maybe planar g3 and again to f5 many
many options I try to get an f5 that
would be it would be something but ok
he's mechanically preventing that k
not a happy move but I want to play 96
them k maybe if he takes takes at least
the FR gets opened
yeah it's still terrible but maybe maybe
I can generate some kind of activity oh
it's difficult to play again sir
essentially unknown opponent where you
can get anything well and you cannot
really tell how how good in place but
how well he plays but you play he played
played a very very ok up to this point
I'm much much worse okay I'm getting I'm
not that I'm having huge hopes here but
sorry for that position was definitely
even worse at some point no question
about that
Rock g5 is very close to working maybe
this move preventing a form
I'd like to play Raghav a look at five
maybe this is not this is not super
clear this position now I think
you cannot move this night sg3 is under
so much pressure and h5 h4 will free up
the way there ok we can check with the
pawn time morning geforce not working
unfortunately my get did he get this end
but ok let's do this check I can check
here
check for queen is seven or what is he
doing check that one okay Queenie seven
check d7 check check I have only 16
seconds I can take and he winced a sad i
blundered that it wasn't a clear
position not in a blitz game at least I
completely let me back into the game
check yeah black resides java he left me
back into this game and didn't didn't
really take this opportunity british
pretty sure at least that it was was
again quite quite okay for me okay so
around here i'm in in bad shape and but
then somehow i got what lots of activity
in and I don't know things things
weren't clear I don't don't really think
so so here when g5 King f12 went back
okay f1 chance to the comms has clear
advantage before age for ticks and ticks
check and check 96 and why does winning
all know I was thinking there might be
something but it was always always so
good for him I mean okay King have one
not really great but it doesn't it
doesn't kill wide yeah I played I played
the opening badly of course I shouldn't
shouldn't get into this bad position
I'm not sure maybe I have to play this I
wasn't sure because of this move hmm h5
is the comb suggestion what makes quite
some sense trying to grab the initiative
I have not I don't know this opening so
well as we have witness this is um yeah
it loses time but the problem is that
he's cried in good shape there on the
dark squares on the light squares I'm
sorry on the on the light squares there
f5 g4 and so on and it's not really good
to this pollution now that was that was
a very bad opening result and it seems
that he played it well them okay well
thanks for watching